- I'm gonna start with you, Jacob.
So be honest.
After making Spider-Man,
what do you really do
when you see a spider in
the room in real life?
A. Kill it.
B. Try to take it outside or
C. Scream and have someone
else take care of it.
Jacob, go.
- So, basically my girlfriend
is really, really not
about hurting animals.
So, I had to learn to like,
to just not be afraid
and scream like a little girl
and like, try to pick it up with a napkin
and kind of lead it out the window.
Um, so I guess I'd do number two,
but inside I'm doing
number three all the time,
which is screaming like a girl.
- I just simply love
that I got you to say,
"I do number two and three sometimes."
(everyone laughing and clapping)
That was-
Jacob, my God.
I love you.
So wait, (Kelly chuckles)
Zendaya, what do you do?
Do you, what do you do?
A, B or C?
Do you kill it?
Do you take it out
or do you scream and go somebody get that?
- [Zendaya] I would actually-
- I'd just do, I do D.
I just ignore it.
(everyone laughs)
I just let it be.
- You ignore it.
- I'm just gonna
leave it there, look away,
you look back, it's gone.
It's not my problem anymore.
(laughs loudly)
- What if it crawls up on
you while you're sleeping?
- Well, the difference
is I live in England,
so none of the spiders
in England can kill you.
U.S. spiders here that can kill you.
- Did you know spiders
can crawl into your mouth when you sleep?
- [Kelly] Yes!
- Apparently, it happens
all the time, bro!
- Yes.
- [Kelly] Yes!
- So, you should definitely
get rid of the spider.
Maybe not kill it, but like get rid of it.
- I definitely take them outside.
I take them outside.
I don't like, I don't like,
I think it's bad luck actually.
- Really?
- To kill one?
Or to leave it outside?
- Yeah, if you find one
you don't have to kill it.
I don't kill bugs in my
house, I take them outside.
It's just a general rule.
I try to convert people
to doing that as well.
- You are good like that.
I just see them as like little guests.
I'm like welcome to the house, man!
(Zendaya laughs)
- Little guests!
- [Tom] Can I get you anything?
- [Zendaya] Your house
is just bug infested.
- Yeah I love it.
- Little roaches.
- But also as Spider-Man,
I feel like you cannot kill a spider.
- What if someone like, (indistinct)
and its really weird?
In my car.
(Jacob laughs)
- They've given you a nice car.
- I'll be driving along, on the dashboard.
- I love that, this angle,
you can see my socks and my sweatpants.
(everyone laughs)
(Kelly laughs loudly)
- [Zendaya] No! No!
- Oh my God!
Actually Zendaya, we couldn't
see that at all here.
That is so awesome. (laughs loudly)
I love Zoom!
Oh my God, that was me for
like a year on this show.
I literally had like a
blouse and like yoga pants,
I didn't do yoga and flip flops.
(laughs loudly)
It was like, it was awesome!
Um, that was amazing.